نشرتنا من تركيا حيث يترقب الجميع ما
ستفرزه صناديق الاقتراع هذه الليله سواء
في الانتخابات الرئاسيه المفصليه وايضا
على مستوى الانتخابات البرلمانيه التي
تشهدها البلاد هذه الانتخابات التي ستغلق
صناديقها في او تغلق صناديقها في هذه
الاثناء وصفت بالمصيريه كونها ستحدد ما
اذا كان الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان سيواصل
حكمه الذي بداه قبل عقدين ام ان المعارضه
بقياده كمال كليتش دار اوغلو ستتمكن من
تحقيق المفاجاه
بالطبع هذه صور مباشره الان لبدء عمليات
الفرز
مع اغلاق صناديق الاقتراع في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه في تركيا عمليات
الفرز كما هو معروف في الانتخابات التركيه
تتم في امكنه صناديق الاقتراع ثم تعلن
النتائج ولكن غير الرسميه قبل منتصف هذه
الليله كما هو معروف اذا بدا عمليات فرز
الاصوات في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
والبرلمانيه في تركيا هذه المشاهد من احد
اقلام الاقتراع او صناديق الاقتراع في
مدينه اسطنبول حيث الثقل الانتخابي الاكبر
في هذه المدينه وبالطبع والتي كما يقال
سترجح كافه مرشح رئاسي على اخر وحتى تحالف
انتخاب برلماني على اخر اذن
بعض المشاهد من احد اقلام الاقتراع او
صناديق الاقتراع في مدينه اسطنبول لبدء
عمليات عد الاصوات او ما يعرف بفرز
الاصوات بعد هذه الانتخابات التي وصفت كما
ذكرنا بالمصريه
والمعلومات تشير الى ان نسب الاقتراع فاقد
كل التوقعات لا بل انها تشكل سابقه على
مستوى الانتخابات في تاريخ تركيا
والى شبكه بالطبع نحن ما زلنا مع هذه
الصور ولكن انتقل الان الى شبكه مراسلين
التي تتابع هذه الانتخابات منذ فتح صناديق
الاقتراع لابوابها وحتى اقفالها وصولا الى
اعلان النتائج معي من انقره مراسل العربيه
زيدان من اسطنبول مفرده العربيه كريستيانو
بيسري ومن كهرمان مرعش موفد العربيه غسان
ابو لوز ابدا من اسطنبول حيث الثقل
الانتخابي الاكبر مع كريستيانو اهلا وسهلا
بك
ابرز ما لفتك حتى الساعه في عمليات
الاقتراع مع اغلاق صناديق الاقتراع الان
رئاسيا برلمانيا جديد المشهد وابرز ما
سجلته كاميرا العربيه كريستيان
اهلا بك يا طالب المشاهدين تعقيبا على
كلامك بالفعل يعني يقال هنا بان من يفوز
باسطنبول يفوز
بتركيا لانها فيها ثقل الاكبر لاعداد
الناخبين يعد هنا حوالي 11 مليون ناخب
وكما ذكرت ايضا في الخبر فقد
شهدت صناديق الاقتراع اقبالا كثيفا بالفعل
فكل التوقعات نتحدث عن حوالي 90% من نسبه
المسجلين فعلا ادلوا باصواتهم بسابقه في
تاريخ تركيا الحديث جميع الانتخابات هنا
مثلا مركز الاقتراع هذا سجل فيه حوالي
6000 ناخب وبالفعل قدم الى هنا واقترع
بصوته حوالي
5600 ناخب وبالتالي النسبه عاليه جدا
بالنسبه لملاحظاتنا
كان واضحا نوعا ما قله مشاركه العنصر
الشبابي في هذه الانتخابات بالمراكز التي
تنقلنا بها في اسطنبول التي تعد نوعا ما
ثقل الانتخابي لحزب العداله والتنميه
لاردوغان فان النسبه الاكبر من المشاركين
كانت من متوسطي الاعمار 40 وما فوق هؤلاء
يقولون بانهم يصوتوا لاردوغان بالرغم من
كل الاخفاقات في العامين الماضيين الازمه
الاقتصاديه وسوء اداره تداعيات الزلزال
وغيرها لانهم جيل شهد تركيا ما قبل حكم
اردوغان لها وما بعده وبالتالي عندما
يضعون الامور في ميزان كما يقولون فان
الدفه تميل لانجازات اردوغان وليس
لاخفاقاته المؤقته كما يقولون وما بين
تغيير وجه البلاد وتغيير يعني
ما يقولون بانه الطابع الاسلامي والمحافظ
لها الذي يحافظ عليها اردوغان وما بين
المعاناه اقتصاديا ولو بفتره مؤقته يفضلون
الازمه الاقتصاديه المؤقته على تغيير صوره
البلاد التي تمثل مبادئهم كما يقولون
ابقي معي سانتقل الى زيدان زنجلو هو معي
من العاصمه انقره زيدان اخر ما لديك وهل
يمكن تلمس اي مؤشرات الى من ذهبت اغلبيه
الاصوات في الدوره الاولى اتكلم عن
الانتخابات الرئاسيه املا هذا رجم بالغيب
ودونه محاذير زيدان
نعم شخص دخل في الكادر نعم بالفعل لا يمكن
التكهن الان
بنتيجه الانتخابات كل المؤشرات خلال
الايام والساعات الماضيه كانت تشير الى
تقارب كبير في حظوظ المرشحين الرئيسيين
نتحدث هنا عن
الرئاسه ما بين مرشح المعارض كمال كلجدار
اوغلو وايضا مرشح الائتلاف الحاكم الرئيس
الحالي رجل طيب اردوغان بالعموم هناك
تقارب كبير لكن انا هنا ساشير الى نقطه
اشارتها زميلتنا كريستيان من اسطنبول فعلا
انا في المنطقه التي اتواجد فيها الان في
منطقه تشانكايا وهي منطقه معروفه وداعمه
لحزب الشعب الجمهوري هي منطقه علمانيه
اتتركيه ان صحت التسميه على وجه التحديد
لم نشهد كثيرا في المراكز التي زرناها
اقبالا من فئه الشباب احدث فقط عن المراكز
التي زورناها ومشاهدات التي رايناها
من مباشره في المراكز حقيقه المشاركه
الشبابيه في المراكز التي زرناها كانت
قليله وضعيفه نوعا ما لكن ننتظر النتائج
النهائيه لنعرف النسبه التي شاركت من
الجيل زد وهو وهي نسبه كبيره كان من
المفرد ان تشارك لكن في حال كانت المشاركه
ضعيفه من هذا الجيل من الجيل زد هذا يؤشر
الى ان الناخبين الشباب لم يكونوا مقتنعين
بكلى الشخصيات التي ترشحت ونتحدث مباشره
هنا عن اردوغان او كليجدار اوغلو لاسيما
ان فئه من الشباب كانت تتطلع الى وجود وجه
شاب وهنا الحديث عن المعارضه وتحديدا
الرئيس بلديه اسطنبول اكرم امام اوغلو
الذي نجح في انتخابات البلديه عام 2019
ربما ننتظر لا نريد ان نتكلم لكن نتحدث عن
مشاهدات الاوليه في حال كان هناك عزوف من
فئه الشباب فهذا ربما ما رده الى
خيبه امل الناخب الشاب بعدم وجود شخصيات
شابه من النقاط التي ذكرناها وذكرناها في
تقرير أنا صورته بقناه العربيه كان هناك
اقبال من الشباب على محرم انجا كان هناك
خيار بديل لاردوغان وكل جدار اوغلو فئه من
جيل زيد كانت تفضل محرم انجا اولا لانه
اصغر سنا وهو يمتلك الحس الخطابي الحماسي
ويلامس احلام وتطلعات الشباب فئه من جيل
زيت كانت تطلع لي التصويت
اوراقه يعني زيدان نتيجه ما سمي
الفيديوهات والتي وصفها بغير الاخلاقيه
الى ما هنالك سعود اليك زيدان ولكن ارجو
ان تتفضل بالبقاء معي سانتقل الان الى
غسان ابو لوز هو معي من كهرمان مرعش غسان
ابرز ما سجلته في هذا اليوم الانتخابي
الطويل وهل بات من المفروغ منه ان الامور
ذاهبه الى جوله ثانيه على مستوى
الانتخابات الرئاسيه ام لا لا يمكن قول
ذلك
طالب حتى اللحظه لا يمكن التنبؤ باي شيء
كان هناك اقبال كبير في هذه الولايه
كهرمان مرعش وفي المراكز الاقتراع التي
تجولت فيها لكن الذهاب الى جوله ثانيه
يعني حتى اللحظه من المبكر الحديث عن هذا
الامر خصوصا ان مراكز الاقتراع والصناديق
اغلقت قبل دقائق من الان وستبدا عمليات
الفرز وخلال الساعات المقبله ستتضح ملامح
المشهد الانتخابي بالضبابي في ظل هذا
التنافس الشديد والاستقطاب الكبير الذي
مرت فيه البلاد طيله الاشهر الماضيه في
كهرمان مرعش طالب هناك 750 الف ناخب يحق
لهم التصويت حيث نقف في هذا احد في احد
هذه المراكز وكما تشاهد من خلفي هناك
كرابانات وضعت لاجراء عمليه التصوير
التصويت والاقتراع في هذه الكربونات بسبب
بان هذه المدرسه التي نقف بالقرب منها
تعرضت للزلزال وهي قايله للسقوط يصلح
للاستخدام البشري وبالتالي وضعت هذه
الكرفانات لاستقبال
المصوطين والناخبين في هذا المكان بحسب
اللجان هنا ابلغونا ان هناك كان اقبال
كبير وشديد جدا على هذا المركز او على هذا
الصندوق في هذا الموقع وايضا كان هناك
اقبال كبير في المراكز الاخرى التي على
الاقل زرتها انا واطلعت عليها وشاهدتها
ورقبت حركه الناخبين يعني كان هناك حركه
من الشباب بالنسبه لتلك المراكز وكان ايضا
هناك حركه من كبار السن ومتوسطي الاعمار
كانوا مقبلين على هذه الانتخابات
وتفاوتت مواقف هؤلاء حول المرشحين منهم من
صوت لاردوغان كما قال بانه يريد ان يحافظ
على هذا الارث لحكومه اردوغان ولرئاسه
اردوغان طيله الفتره الماضيه العشرين سنه
الماضيه ومنهم من يريد التخلص من حكومه
اردوغان والرئيس اردوغان وبالتالي الذهاب
نحو يعني كالجدار اوغلو وانتخاب كل جدار
اوغلو وكما قالوا هؤلاء انه انهم يريدون
التغيير ويريدون الديمقراطيه وايضا يريدون
العداله هناك فئه اخرى تبحث لم تفصح عن
شخص المرشح الذي انتخبته لكن كانت واضحه
بانها تريد حياه افضل وتريد تحسين المستوى
المعيشي تتحدث عن وضع اقتصادي صعب عن تضخم
وعن انهيار الليره او ارتفاع يعني قيمه
الليره امام الدولار وايضا اضافه الى ذلك
تاتي كارثه الزلزال التي فاقمت من معانات
هؤلاء الموجودين ونتحدث عن اكثر من ثلاثه
اشهر مرت على كارثه زلزال ولا مازال
المتضررون موجودون في الخيام وموجودون في
الكربونات طالب وهم يعني يطالبون السلطات
بالاسراع لكن نحن الان في
استحقاق انتخابي وبانتظار النتائج المقبله
وعلى بطبيعه الحال طالب يعني ايا كان من
سيفوز بهذه الانتخابات سيواجه صعوبه في
مواجهه ملف تداعيات كارثه الزلزال بسبب
الحجم الهائل الذي ضرب زلزال الذي ضرب هذه
المناطق نتحدث عن 500 كيلو متر مربع عن 11
ولايه عمليا طالب او تاريخيا هذه الولايات
تحديدا ولايه كهرمان مرعش ولايات اخرى هي
تاريخيا تصوت لحزب العداله والتنميه لكن
كما قلت سابقا في ظل الاستقطاب السابق
الشديد والمنافسه الشديده حتى الان المشهد
ضبابي جدا وما زلنا يعني بانتظار النتائج
التي ستصدر عن صناديق الاقتراع وصناديق
الاقتراع ستجيب عن هذه الاسئله التي يمت
تنتظرها عموم البلاد
غسان كريستيان وزيدان والله اسمائكم لحسن
الحظ على نفس القافيه يعني ابقوا معي
ساعود اليكم بعد قليل اعزائي المشاهدين
توزعت العمليه الانتخابيه في تركيا على
اكثر من 190 الف صندوق اختراع اذا هناك 60
مليون المناخب مسجلون بينهم نحو خمسه
ملايين ناخب يشاركون لاول مره في التصويت
اي ما يقرب من ثمانيه بالمئه من الناخبين
اما الشباب فيرى الكثيرون انهم اكبر
مجموعه من الناخبين المتارجحين اما
الاكراد الذين يمثلون ما يتراوح بين 15
و20% من اجمالي ناخبين فينظر اليهم على ان
لهم دورا محوريا في هذه الانتخابات حزب
الشعوب الديمقراطي الموالي للاكراد ليس
جزءا من تحالف المعارضه لكنه يناصب
اردوغان معارضه شديده على خلفيه حمله قمع
استهدفت اعضائه
وتجري الانتخابات التشريعيه على 600 مقعد
حيث يخوض السباق 24 حزبا سياسيا ومئه واحد
151 مرشحا مستقلا وجرت الانتخابات وسط
اجراءات امنيه مشدده حيث قال وزير
الداخليه التركي ان اكثر من 600 الف عنصر
امن تولي مهمه التامين الانتخابات
[موسيقى]
اعود الى شبكه مراسلين الذين يغطون هذه
الانتخابات المفصليه والتاريخيه في تركيا
كريستيانو من اسطنبول النتائج الليله الكل
سيقبل بها كما قال او كما يعني صرح ايا
تكن النتائج هل الامور تشي بالنسبه اليك
من خلال متابعتك على الاقل على المستوى
انتخابات الرئاسيه ان الامور ذاهبه باتجاه
دوره ثانيه هذا واحد اثنين على المستوى
الانتخابات البرلمانيه هل من مؤشرات
يعني تشير الى فوز تحالف
بشكل او باخر على الاقل في اسطنبول ام لا
لا يمكن رصد مثل هكذا مؤشرات
يمكن الحديث عن او الحديث عن نتائج
الانتخابات البرلمانيه اكثر من نتائج
الانتخابات الرئاسيه البعض هنا يقول بان
المعارضه يمكن ان تتقدم بالانتخابات
البرلمانيه وبالتالي حتى لو فاز اردوغان
ستكون مهمته صعبه من حيث تشريع القوانين
ولكن فيما يتعلق بالانتخابات الرئاسيه لا
احد يمكن ان يتكهن بنتائجه حتى يعني الكل
يقول بانها ستكون مفاجاه
نحن هنا بدات عمليه الفارس من المتوقع بعد
ساعتين يعني بحوالي السابعه مساء بتوقيت
تركيا ان يبدا اعلان النتائج الاوليه يعني
نتائج النهائيه والرسميه تعلن بعد يومين
ولكن يكون هناك نوعا ما اجواء الى من
ستذهب يعني او من سيفوز بهذه الانتخابات
يعني استطلعنا اراء ليس فقط المواطنين
وانما حتى المسؤولين قدموا الى مراكز
الاقتراع التي جلنا عليها
تعرف طاهر بانه باحوال مماثله بعمليات
الانتخابيه يكون هناك نوعا ما حرب نفسيه
وبالتالي كان
مسؤولو العداله والتنميه يقولون باننا
سنفوز بهذه الانتخابات كل المؤشرات تدل
على ذلك وكذلك مسؤولية المعارضه كان لديهم
نفس
التصريحات بانهم هم سيفوزون بهذه
الانتخابات وبالتالي من الصعب التكهن
بالنتائج ولكن باسطنبول على الاقل
بالاحياء التي
جلنا فيها التي تفقدنا مراكز الاقتراع
فيها النسبه الاكبر من الذين صوتوا كانت
لحزب العداله والتنميه بحكم ان ثقل
الانتخابي للرئيس اردوغان هنا في هذه
الاحياء في اسطنبول كريستيان يبقى معي
دعني اعود الى زيدان زيدان في العمل 2017
يعني صحح لي اذا كنت مخطئ حول رجب طيب
اردوغان النظام السياسي في تركيا من
برلمان الى رئاسه مركزي في حال خساره
اردوغان هذه الانتخابات يعني لنفترض في
حال خساره الرئيس اردوغان هذه الانتخابات
هل تمت حديث عن العوده الى النظام
البرلماني من قبل مرشح المعارضه كمال
كتيتشدار اوغلو ام لا لا وجود لمثل هكذا
كلام
نعم هو برنامجه الانتخابي لزعيم المعاضه
كمال كلجدار اوغلو العوده الى النظام
البرلماني وهناك مرحله انتقاليه
ستكون فاصله ما بين الانتقال من النظام
الرئاسي الذي جرى الاستفتاء عليه كما
تفضلت في عام 2017 في شهر نيسان شهر نيسان
ابريل 2017 الى النظام البرلماني المعدل
بحسب ما يقول زعيم المعارضه التركيه لماذا
المعدل لان شريحه كبيره من الناخبين
الاتراك يخشون
الاخطاء التي كانت موجوده في النظام
البرلماني السابق والذي ادى ويسمونه نظام
الحكومات الائتلافيه التي ادت الى
انهيار تلك الحكومات الى ازمات سياسيه
واقتصاديه عنيفه عصفت بالبلاد لذلك كلجدار
اوغلو كان يعد بالعوده الى النظام
البرلماني لكن المعدل والمعزز لتلافي تلك
الاخطاء
هفوات التي كانت في النظام السابق
وبالتالي عدم تشكيل حكومات ائتلافيه لكن
على الطرف المقابل هناك من ينتقد كلجد
ويقول بان تحالفه تحالف الطاوله السداسيه
هو شكل جديد هو النسخه نسخه 2023 من تلك
الحكومات الائتلافيه باعتبار انه ست زعماء
من سته احزاب من من مختلف التيارات سواء
محافظين او قوميين او يمين وسط او يسار
هناك اليه وضعتها الطاوله السداسيه وتوافق
عليها زعماء الطاوله السداسيه لانه عند
اختيار او عند القرارات واتخاذ القرار يجب
ان يكون القرار بالتوافق وهذه حق حقيقه
مشكله ادت في الاختبار الاول وهو اختيار
المرشح مرشح المعارضه كمالك لجدار اوغلو
الى انسحاب ميرال اكشنال من الطاوله
السداسيه ثم العوده لذلك منتقدوك الجدار
اوغلو يغمزون من هذه الزاويه الى ان
الطاوله السداسيه او فكره الى النظام
البرلماني ربما ضررها اكثر من نفعها بينما
مؤيدوك الجدار اوغلو يقولون ان زمن الفرد
الواحد في اشاره الى الرئيس اردوغان يجب
ان يتغير وان تعود البلاد الى نظام
برلماني له سلطه كامله وان يكون الرئيس
بمنصف فخري طيب زيدان
معي ساعود اليكم اعزائي
المراسلين الى
هذا اعزائي المشاهدين من جانبه
التركي فؤاد اقطاي ان حزب العداله
والتنميه الحاكم سيحترم نتائج الانتخابات
اي ان تكن واضاف ان الاقبال على التصويت
في الانتخابات الرئاسيه كثيف جدا مشيرا
الى ان هدف حزب العداله والتنميه ان تكون
هذه الانتخابات نزيهه وشفافه
وان يجلب الديمقراطيه والحداثه
والتعليل البلاد
اولئك الذين يستمعون الى هذا يمكنهم
بالفعل تخمين من هو
جئت للتصويت اعتقد ان الاقبال سيكون
مرتفعا الشخص الذي سيفوز في الانتخابات
سيفوز بفارق ثلاث او اربع نقاط
هذا العام مهم جدا السنوات السابقه كانت
ايضا مهمه جدا ولكن الان نحن كشعب سئمنا
من بعض الاشياء لا اريد الخوض في هذه
القضايا لكن هناك مشاكل باقتصاد البلد
واشياء كثيره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذهب الى غسان ابو العز في كهرمان مرعش
غسان في حديث عن مسالتين اساسيتين في
المناطق التي ضربها الزلزال
يعني كهرمان مرعش يعني كانت من المدن او
الولايات التي ضربها الزلزال بشده وان
تداعيات الزلزال كانت حاضره تماما في هذه
الانتخابات اضافه الى موضوع اللاجئين
السوريين او النازحين السوريين هل فعلا
شكل هذان العاملان هويه في هذه الانتخابات
وفق متابعتك ام لا يعني الاولويات كانت
للاقتصاد للبطاله ولغيرها من الامور
لكل هذه الامور طالب بالفعل كان هذان
الملفان موجودين يعني نحن تابعنا مع
الناخبين الذين كانوا يدلون باصواتهم ثم
نخرجهم ونسالهم نسالهم لماذا لماذا
تنتخبون وماذا تريدون من المرشح او الرئيس
المقبل احدى الفتيات قالت بانها لا تريد
ان ترى السوريين في كهرمان مرعش عشر سنوات
يكفي عشر سنوات لوجود السوريين في كهرمان
مرعش وبالتالي هي لا تريد وجود السوريين
في كرما مرعش مثل هذه الفتاه ينطبق عليها
الكثير في كهرمان مرعش وفي ولايات اخرى
ايضا اضافه الى ملف تداعيات الزلزال ايضا
سيطرت على المشهد الانتخابي في هذه
الولايه وفي جميع الولايات بطبيعه الحال
طالب هناك مطالب من المواطنين تحديدا من
المواطنين المتضررين والذين ما زالوا
لغايه الان يعيشون في الخيام ويعيشون في
الكربونات قبل قليل كنا عند احد مراكز
الاقتراع كان هنا مركز اختراع في مدرسه
وبالقرب منها في س خاليه كان هناك لحدود
20 خيمه موجوده ما زالوا مقيمين في هذه
الخيام منذ اكثر من ثلاثه شهور وبالتالي
مثل هؤلاء الاشخاص الان يبحثون عن الملذ
الامن يبحثون عن المنازلون هذه الحياه
الكريمه ويطالبون السلطات بتامين هذه
الحياه الكريمه
فهذا يعني شكل ضغط على بالنسبه للمواطنين
موجودين في كهرمان هل هذا غير من توجهاتهم
او من
سنكون معك مع باقي الزملاء في النشرات
لاحقه وفي تغطياتنا اللاحقه
لمجريات العماليه الانتخابيه مع بدء صدور
النتائج في الساعات المقبله غسان ابو لوز
من كهرمان مرعش شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا ايضا
لكريستيان بيسري كانت معي من اسطنبول
وايضا من انقره مراسل العربيه زيدان شكرا
جزيلا لك زيدان